the Speaker of the House have a
responsibility to work with the
President of the United States of my
party or otherwise I have we all have a
responsibility to the American people to
to try to find our common ground for
their benefit where we can't find our
common ground though we have an
obligation to stand our ground I will do
everything I possibly can and encourage
my colleagues to do so to make sure we
have a Democratic president of the
United States country cannot handle four
more years of George Bush's policies he
has taken us to the brink and Iraq Frank
on the economy endangered our fiscal
response time this and the budget
endangered the preservation of the
planet nothing less is at stake than the
planet the budget the Constitution of
the United States it's impossible to
exaggerate the importance of this race
and I say to all who have participated
in the presidential elections god bless
you for your participation and your
loyalty to your candidates along the way
but everyone in this country who cares
about working families in our country
has so much to gain from the election of
barack obama as president so much to
lose by the election of John McCain I
can't even think about the prospect of
public and president not at the moment
but yes of course I would be prepared to
work with
with Senator McCain